well good evening thank you all for
finding us with our change location and
thank you all for coming there are some
additional seats I think up front here
that won't be needed if you want to just
save a couple of those at the end okay
now that now that that's done well I'm
Nancy yes you know versity Press of
Virginia and we're very pleased to have
you here we're very pleased to be
sponsoring this early event in the
Virginia festival for the book and we're
very pleased to to be publisher of the
book that is the occasion for this
evenings program um this is one of the
early events of the Virginia festival
for the book which is organized and run
by volunteers and produced by the
Virginia Foundation for the Humanities
with the goal of promoting literacy
reading and lifelong learning with
support from private and corporate
sponsorship all festival events are open
to the public and most are free and we
were asked to say that and we're glad to
glad to do so let me just briefly plug
another festival event that the press is
sponsoring and one that is near and dear
to us to this each year the American
Association of University presses hosts
a competition to select the best design
University Press books published during
that year and after the selections are
made the show travels throughout the
country the AAUP books show of 55 books
and 27 jackets is on display at the
Magothy Art Center throughout the
festival for people like all of us who
love
the look and feel of books as well as
what's in them it's a great opportunity
to consortin siddur what goes into
bookmaking and you can also get a copy
of this neat catalogue which describes
the books and gives judges comments
about them something we hope you have a
chance to check that out too now back to
mr. Jefferson's dome room we're pleased
that you found us here and we're sorry
that there isn't quite room for for
everyone who found us - to find a seat
perhaps we can persuade a net
gordon-reed to come back again when her
book is officially published on April
13th although not yet officially
published one of those strange
publishing customs you'll say I hasten
to add that books are available tonight
downstairs afterwards tonight man is the
first public discussion of Thomas
Jefferson and Sally Hemings an American
controversy how appropriate as you've
all already noted no doubt to have this
premiere discussion reverberating
through mr. Jefferson's rotunda as
indeed the subject of the controversy
has reverberate throughout history more
strongly than ever it seems into our
times if as Ken Burns has said
repeatedly Thomas Jefferson is the man
of the millennium race is certainly the
issue of the millennium in this country
how necessary it seems to bring them
together to attempt to look at them
clearly we and others who have read her
work think that a net gordon-reed has
done the definitive bringing together a
net gordon-reed grew up in Texas
received a bachelor's degree in history
from Dartmouth College and then went on
to Harvard Law School ms goin read
practice law with a private firm in New
York City from 1984 to 87 then serve
chief legal officer for the New York
City Board of Corrections from 1987
until 1992 and since then she has taught
at New York law school she now has
combined her lifelong interest in
history with her well honed legal skills
to look at the evidence regarding mr.
Jefferson and niz Hemings and at how
historians have treated it and but to
thank everybody for coming to this event
I know that there's other competition
out there poets and other historians I
have to confess when I got the program
from the Virginia festival of the book
and the title of my talk was Thomas
Jefferson and Sally Hemings a lawyer
makes her case I was a little alarmed
because I wasn't really sure what that
was supposed to mean and what I was
supposed to be doing up here and the
more I thought about it I became more
alarmed because I have a feeling that
many of you probably have a very clear
idea of what I'm supposed to be doing up
here I think I hope I've hit upon
something that will meet your
expectations and that I don't disappoint
I want to say a little bit about this
lawyer business I am NOT and never have
and I hope never will be a trial lawyer
my husband and some of my friends do
that but I have practice law and I am a
law professor and my job now along with
my colleagues is to teach men and women
the skills that they need to become
effective lawyers those skills are many
but the most important one I think is
the ability to think critically about
problems and to solve problems and most
people see lawyers just as advocates and
that's one thing that we do but it's a
narrow slice of a lawyers function
lawyers advise clients about many things
about their estates about investments
lawyers are involved when people try to
adopt children and one theme runs
throughout
all of the lawyers role in those
situations and that is the seriousness
of the enterprise that's involved
lawyers hold aspects of people's lives
in their hands and if you're talking
about criminal law they hold their
actual lives in their hands so it's very
very important to approach those matters
with seriousness and care and gather as
much information about the situation as
you can before you come to a conclusion
that's why it's important to teach
people the skills that I talked about
the ability to see matters as being
serious to gather information that's
relevant not to rely upon other people's
judgment when you've taken it upon
yourself to answer a question and
particularly the hazard of giving short
shrift
to alternative viewpoints those are all
skills that are necessary for the lawyer
but of course these are skills that are
required in other endeavors as well and
I think that we intuitively use them
ourselves whenever we're confronted with
a problem your child breaks a vase and
there's a controversy about what
happened I think we employ all of the
things that I talked about before as a
way of getting at the heart of a matter
even as trivial as that may or may not
be and certainly the aim of any good
liberal arts education is to build upon
and hone critical thinking skills so
that the student can go on to whatever
to function perfectly or well and
whatever endeavor that they choose to to
explore which brings me to the case that
I'm supposed to be making tonight and
the one that I make in my book about the
way the discussion of Thomas Jefferson
and Sally Hemings has proceeded over the
years I've noticed and I've been
extremely frustrated by the almost
complete failure to employ basic and
elemental problem-solving skills
and scholars approach to this particular
issue I think I know at least some of
the reasons for that and we can talk
about that later on but I want to make
the case now that my observation is
correct I imagine most of you know
basic outlines of the story when
Jefferson was in his first term a
muckraking journalist James Callender
published a story alleging that he was
involved with Sally Hemings who was an
enslaved woman on his plantation this
gossip about this alleged relationship
had been going on for some period before
calendar published it we don't really
know but calendar was the first one to
put it into the mainstream and just as
one might expect the Republican pressed
Jefferson's party denied the story and
the Federalists his enemies exploited
the story and tried to use it for
political gain calendar died not long
after publishing the report and the
issue itself died down for a while and
just sort of resurfaced periodically
whenever anybody wanted to attack
Jefferson so you may also know that the
Jefferson family disputed the story and
pointed the finger at two of Jefferson's
nephews one or two of his nephews the
Carr brothers in 1873 a man named
Madison Hemings who was the son of Sally
Hemings gave an interview to an Ohio
newspaper reporter in which he said that
he was the son of Thomas Jefferson and
Sally Hemings so what we have here is I
think a story that is relatively
straightforward it's not some terribly
complicated matter that requires
specialized knowledge on the part of
anybody who would consider it my legal
history professor a man named Morton
Horowitz used to warn us about what he
called the cult of complexity when
people say that an issue is just too
complicated for ordinary people to
understand and that the only people who
can give an answer are the only people
who can even formulate the right
questions or experts I don't think we
have that in this situation what we have
someone said that a man who is a master
was the father of a slave woman's
children we have access to information
about the man lots of access to
information lots of information we don't
know as much about the woman we also
have access to information about the
nature of the slaves
system and how it responded to
miscegenation and we can also draw upon
our own experiences as human beings to
answer this question or to find the most
likely answer to this question I believe
that anybody who undertakes to give an
answer to this question or I should say
the most likely answer to this question
has a responsibility to de frst develop
a workable and sensible strategy for
dealing with the question that would
involve keeping what is a basic feature
of any problem-solving technique in mind
and that is that you never begin by
taking something that is humanly
possible off the table
I think that's true whether you're
talking about trying to find out why an
airplane crashed whether someone is
attempting to break a code or whether
you're dealing with a historical mystery
the reason you can't take anything off
the table is that if you're not present
at the time at the relevant time if
you're not present when something was
supposed to have happened you can't
possibly know for certain what did or
did not happen you have to have we're at
a disadvantage if you're not there the
other problem is if you start by taking
something that is humanly possible off
the table you have an investment in
making sure that it stays off the table
you inject yourself into the story in a
way that personalizes it it makes it
about not just about the issue but about
you and your own judgement so when
somebody comes along and says or tries
to put it back on the table by saying
hey have you considered this they're not
only dealing with the story they are in
effect attacking you that's the
perception that happens when you take
something off the table and have an
interest in making sure that it stays
off the table the only thing you can do
if you're truly trying to make a
good-faith attempt to answer a question
or answer what is to find out what is
the probable truth which is what you
really have when you're talking about
history probable truth a continuum for
things that are not probable or highly
unlikely to things that are probable
most things in history are not based
upon definitive proof
what you have to do is gather as much
information as you can not assume that
because you have a hunch that something
is a right that that is in effect the
answer you can't let your initial
reactions keep you from asking questions
that should be asked and also making the
most reasonable inferences from the
information as it turns up so again we
have an allegation that a man who is a
master was the father of the slave
woman's children I'll bet we could all
come up with some good and relevant
questions that should be asked about
that situation this is not about whether
Jefferson is in the vanguard of modern
liberalism or his philosophy grew out of
country versus court politics or
whatever this is something that requires
you you know things like that require
you to digest a lot of specific material
and information this is something that
would have happened in the realm of the
personal we're all part of families we
know the strengths and weaknesses of
families we understand something about
the way they operate
now slavery was a special time this is
something that we don't deal with but
it's a special time but I would imagine
that one of the first things that
someone would want to ask if when it
when confronting an allegation that a
man was the father of a slave or slave
woman's children is whether any words
deeds or circumstances that signal a
connection between the man and the
children and the mother did he act
toward them in a way that indicated that
they were special to him did he do
things that we know from our own
experiences signal a likely parental
connection and for most people the
question is did he free them there are
other questions that you ask about them
are there other things about the
children that link them to him what do
they look like what are their names
was there any contemporary talk about
the alleged relationship what about the
woman are there any indications that her
life was different than other women on
the plantation did any of his friends
ever say anything about this in the case
of Jefferson and Hemings it turns out
that there are answers to all of these
questions and I think any reasonable
person
whether they believe the story or not
would see that these types of questions
are relevant and the kinds of things
that could have been asked the questions
that I just raised could have been asked
and could have been answered and all the
years that we've been going round and
round the mulberry bush on this question
but the problem with conducting the kind
of freewheeling inquiry that I'm
suggesting is that you can't control the
outcome when you allow for freedom of
thought and freedom of inquiry you might
encourage other people to wander off
into directions that you don't want them
to go so what have historians and when I
say historians I'm basically focusing on
and I do in my book on the Jefferson
scholars who have dealt with this
question what have they done to
forestall the possibility that people
wander off they've sought to control the
parameters of the discussion by
narrowing limiting the scope of the
questions that can be asked most of the
writing on Jefferson and Hemings share a
common approach the belief that the sole
source to look for to answer the
question of whether Jefferson was
involved in Hemings is Jefferson's
personality in this universe the kind of
questions that I just raised have no
application they're irrelevant no matter
what evidence is turned up the answer
will always be we don't care how
suggestive it looks we don't care what
this information in first we know
Jefferson and we know that his
personality would never allow for this
type of relationship evidence can't
possibly matter and this is which brings
me back to the point that I made about
injecting oneself into the story and
making it a part of you as opposed to
looking at the story as a curiosity
something that you look at and you want
to try to find an answer to the question
is not how much evidence it is the real
question is what do I have to give up if
I say I believe this story what do I
give up personally if other people
believe his story this story and the
more the person thinks that he has to
give up he or she has to give up the
standard of evidence is ratcheted higher
to the point that it's that what is
required is something beyond
what you typically require in history as
I said most of history is not based upon
definitive proof but if you have a stake
in something not being true the only way
that you can deal with it is to make
definitive proof the standard and that
comes not because you're looking at the
issue we can't have total objectivity
but with even any semblance of
objectivity the issue is looked at in
terms of I lose something if people
believe this story and that is what has
happened in this situation now you can
see I have a problem with that approach
The Jeffersons personality is the sole
source of information what you should
look to to answer this question and
there are lots of reasons first is
circular it's a circular argument but
there are the problem that I wanted to
focus upon is that we never answer a
question about whether or not someone
did something solely by referencing that
individuals personality person a is said
to have done something and person B is
sent out to find out whether or not
person a actually did it person B talks
to all of person AIDS friends his family
and for good measure person day's
enemies to find out what kind of person
he is
and then person B comes the back and
says well I've determined after my
investigation that person a couldn't
have done it because he wasn't the kind
of person to do that I don't think that
anybody would take this as a serious let
alone thorough consideration of the
matter yet this is an effect what
Jefferson scholars have done with this
issue a person's personality and
character are important they may be
central to the inquiry but it's only a
part of it it's a part of it at some
point the investigator would have to ask
what happened what actually happened to
the other people in the story are there
circumstances are there facts or they're
things for us to look at that can tell
us the answer
personality is part of it but it cannot
be everything I think the focus on
Jefferson's personality put other
scholars off the game because it
suggests that well it's so Payton Lee
inadequate I think as a method of
analysis that it suggests that there
must not be anything out there I mean if
they're focusing on Jefferson's
personality there can't be anything
else out there to look at that could
give us a likely answer and it's
acceptable in this context because we're
used to thinking that there's nothing
that we know about slaves not much is
known about the lives of slaves the only
problem with that is that in the
hemings's we don't have a typical set of
slaves a lot is known about the Hemings
family and a lot of the information
could have served over the years as a
springboard to make a more thorough
investigation of this particular issue
so it isn't true that we don't know
anything about them and so that that is
a problem and people assume that and we
assume that to our detriment so while
scholars were sort of busy arguing that
Jefferson could not have been involved
with Hemings because he was a Southern
gentleman because he loved his white
family too much to have been involved in
this kind of relationship because he had
no interest in sex and was feminine as
Henry Adams referred to him well that he
was too racist to have sex with a black
person all things that depend upon a
view of his personality there were in
fact things that you would look to that
might indicate what the likely answer is
to this story but it was never looked at
so finally why does this matter to me
mattered to me enough that I would sit
down and write a book about it their
number of reasons and I don't have time
to go into all of them now and we can
talk about them later though I think
well one thing that comes to me is that
Jefferson matters a lot it offends me
actually to see the life of a person as
important to this country as he is
handled and what I think is a
superficial manner people make
statements about Jefferson and
Jefferson's personality sweeping
statements about his personality and
character that are never required to
meet any standard of proof at all I mean
the standard of proof is someone else
said it how do you know it this person
said it I mean I have a pet project in
mind to draw up a list of all of the
things that we supposedly know about
Jefferson and his personality see who
said it first and investigate or
consider the amount of evidence that
they had for that proposition it's
usually going to be
it's so because he said it he's an
eminent historian it is true because he
got it from someone else and it's
people's interpretation and not anything
that's based upon or actually defended
upon the basis of any standard of
evidence so that's one reason it matters
to me the other reason it matters is
that the hemings's matter a great deal
to as members of a group of people whose
lives have not been thought to matter
very much slavery has been defined as
America's original sin and it was a
system based upon race and we're all
black people and white people living
with the results of that whether we
understand it or whether we are
conscious of it or not I am convinced
that the inability to take Madison
Hemings His Word seriously and the
overall failure to look into the lives
of the Hemings family for clues about
their relationship to Jefferson is a
legacy of slavery both of those things
grow right out of our experience the
experiences of slavery the concern has
never been about being fair to a group
of people who were held in bondage the
concern was about protecting certain
people's image of the man who held them
I think if we want to go forward as
Americans these types of issues have to
be dealt with in a very serious and
mutually respectful manner the case that
I ultimately wanted to make is that the
treatment of the Jefferson Hemings story
has undermined that goal for a very very
long time I know this is a very tough
issue for lots of people and I think if
we can be fair about this we can be fair
about almost anything and historians as
teachers I think have an obligation to
serve as examples of other people
examples to other people about how to
deal with issues like this and people
who write about Jefferson and the other
individuals who lived at Monticello can
make them live in a way that has meaning
for us today and I think that that's
what history is supposed to be about
thank
well we'll have time for questions and
discussion later our second speaker is
lucia collier stanton better known
foreign white is cinder she has been at
Monticello in various research
capacities since 1975 she is now senior
research historian at the International
Center for Jefferson studies at
Monticello where she is responsible for
advanced research and writing projects
currently on slavery and Monticello
african-american community she's also
responsible for the University of
Virginia internship program there for
public speaking on a variety of topics
and for the getting word oral history
project on descendants of the Monticello
enslaved community miss Stanton has Co
edited the volume Thomas Jefferson's
move memorandum books forthcoming in the
papers of Thomas Jefferson and her essay
those who labor for my happiness Thomas
Jefferson and his slaves from the
well-known Jeffersonian legacies volume
has been republished as slavery at
Monticello in the Monticello monograph
series
two years ago I looked in my appointment
book I saw I had an appointment with a
law professor who wanted to talk about
Sally Hemings and I thought well this
will take an hour or so and that will be
the end of it well Annette walked
through the door we started talking and
a whole day went by we we talked for the
better part of a day at Monticello and I
was it was a really stimulating
experience because she had an incredible
command of the material and asked
questions of it that I had never thought
to ask myself and so I realized that
what had walked through the door was my
Savior because I had been afraid that I
was going to have to write a book about
this topic myself
and because what we'd known for a while
was that most people who had opinions on
this topic had only fragments of
information to bring to bear which they
kind of waved around in support of their
various positions which were basically
from instinct rather than rational
thought and the the books then available
could not really equip people to discuss
this topic rationally both sides were
too ready to believe for the wrong
reasons either they talked about that
liar and scam scoundrel James Thomson
calendar or they talked about the Randi
car brothers and on the other side
people said well everybody did it then
why not Thomas Jefferson as well and I'm
really hopeful that Annette's book will
bring an end to emotional judgments on
this issue those of you who have read it
know it gives a really unclouded field
of vision on this topic and it can't
provide the whole picture that may never
be possible but it's the clearest view
that we have yet had because it isn't
the whole picture though I do want to
differ
on one issue with Annette and that I
don't think that we should throw out of
court the whole personality character
issue I think this still has some some
part in this whole issue no one can
really categorically deny the
possibility of this relationship on that
basis but since we're dealing with
probabilities rather than certainties
there is room for personal opinion based
on a consideration of Jefferson's
actions and writings as we know them
in the absence of conclusive proof one
way or the other I think we have to call
on Jefferson as a witness in this case
we've got to recognize that he's
provided us with his own version of what
his personality or character was but I
think that people are still can bring
Jefferson to bear in coming to their own
personal judgments about this issue also
a requirement should be that everyone
should read and that's book I think it's
going to be really interesting to see
the effect of reading Annette's book on
the mountain at Monticello
Monticello seems to always be seen as a
single entity Monticello says this or
Monticello won't tell you about that
rather than a combination of a hundred
people with different points of view but
I think it's also been perceived that
Monticello has a stake in the untruth of
this story that they have a stake in
denying it and I've worked there
actually since the late 60s at
Monticello and I've never seen anything
to indicate this but what was true is
that in those days nobody believed the
story and I what we what we care most
about there now is historical truth or I
really should say our best shot at
historical truth and you can be sure
that if any of us stumbled on The
Smoking Gun we'd be the first people out
there with the scoop scooping the story
and telling telling the world if it
really was something some kind of
conclusive proof
but there is one big big problem and
that problem is Thomas Jefferson himself
he has a potent almost a bewitching
effect on us his political enemies those
who had never met him who deplored his
stand on various issues would be ushered
into his presence and they'd wonder what
all the fuss would be about was about at
first because he was very wooden and
remote on first acquaintance but then
hours later they would emerge totally
enchanted by this man and his
conversation and that happens today I've
noticed that over the years that for
someone who reads a lot learns a lot
about Thomas Jefferson it becomes harder
and harder for them to fit him into his
alleged role in this relationship that
we're talking about and I know many
people who started as believers who were
convinced by Vaughn Brody's book then
they began to take up the study of
Jefferson read more and became more and
more skeptical on this issue but we have
also been a guy elective testimony that
has been presented to us in by the
historians that Annette talks about in
her book and it's taken us a while to
see the realities of the situation we've
been slowly learning over the years
Michael Dury who wrote the biography of
James Thompson calendar showed us that
although he was still a pretty nasty
fellow he was not a liar he told what he
heard Jim bears works work on the
Hemings family which I'm trying to
follow in his footsteps by by working on
that as well
he showed us that Sally Hemings and her
family members were significant
individuals in themselves and Madison
Hemings recollections outside the the
issue at hand
are strikingly sincere and level-headed
and he's also a really acute observer of
Thomas Jefferson himself and when I
which what I've been doing for the last
three years go to Madison Hemings farm
in Ohio which looks like very much like
this area and talk to his descendants
one of them actually knew his daughter
walked through the buildings that he
constructed these recollections of his
take on even another dimension of
validity getting word that you heard
about his mana chela's oral history
project and Diane Swan right and I have
been over the last three years
interviewing descendants of the
Monticello slave community over seventy
people so far about two-thirds of them
are descendants of Sally Hemings and two
of her sisters and we hear from them the
story of descent from Jefferson that has
been passed down over seven generations
in one case a boy was taken by the hand
by his great aunt to the family Bible
and told the story and another boy went
with his family to Washington DC to see
the historic sights and that was the
occasion his father chose to tell him
and in another case a girl won a dar
History prize and she didn't want to
accept it until her grandmother told her
the story
our aim with this project is to learn
how the story kept people connected to
their past how the connection to
Monticello influenced their lives but
not to measure the story's credibility
and to give you an idea of the
perception of some of the descendants I
just got a letter this week from one in
which she wrote it was this connection
which enabled their parents and
grandparents to acquire some degree of
education and skill and subsequently
property that set them apart outside of
all this I do think
the issue is a suitable topic for
historical debate but not to the point
of squeezing out other issues we kind of
get upset at Monticello because this is
the first thing in everybody's minds and
there's so many other fascinating things
to learn about Thomas Jefferson not to
mention Sally Hemings herself and the
other slaves at Monticello the Hemings
family was far more than one woman who
may or may not have been one man's
mistress Elizabeth Hemings known as
Betty Hemings had at least 12 children
over 70 of her children grandchildren
great children grandchildren lived in
slavery at Monticello and because we
know so much more about this family we
know about remarkable people and
remarkable lives Betty Hemings great
grandchildren and other Monticello
slaves founded a church right after the
Civil War and emancipation in this
county that is still thriving today
another line had descendants who were
among the first african-american
teachers in Albemarle County after the
Civil War and beyond Albemarle County
her descendants are part of a long and
still continuing string of community
leaders in religious life in education
and in anti-slavery activity several of
them were a prominent champions of
racial justice among them Lewis Woodson
and William Monroe Trotter as well so I
just want to close by saying that we
don't want to lose sight of the people
who lived inside the institution of
slavery their lives their
accomplishments and their struggles
against the pressures of the enslaved
condition the getting word project has
given us wonderful insights about the
people of Monticello majority community
we learn about Peter Fawcett teaching
his fellows
to learn to read in the dead of night we
learn about Betsy Ann Isaac's helping
slaves to reach safety
in the Underground Railroad or of Robert
Hughes going from plantation to
plantation bringing the Word of God and
we can better understand the constant
vigilance necessary in the enslaved
community to protect their customary
rights to protect their family integrity
and to build skills and community in
preparation for freedom so in a strange
way I just realized this when I was
thinking about and that's talk and what
I wanted to say tonight in a strange way
much of what we know has been preserved
because of the Jefferson Hemings
controversy because of the families
belief in their descent from Jefferson
which is connected kept them connected
to their ancestors I don't know my fifth
great-grandparents but all of them do
and because the story has been in the
news off and on for almost 200 years
this has made it possible to trace them
today
and to hear and preserve their stories
and whatever the biological nature of
their connection to Monticello events
they're 200 years ago had a profound
impact on seven generations of Americans
that they wish to share their story and
I think is a gift which we must honor by
sharing it with a larger audience and
giving helping to give voice to those
whose lives and achievements went
unrecorded thanks
our third speaker this evening is Roger
Wilkins who joins us from George Madison
Georgia Mason George Mason University
where he has been Clarence Jay Robinson
professor of history and American
culture since 1988 he has had several
other very illustrious careers as well
as a journalist mr. Wilkins has been
editor editorial board member or
columnist or all of the above for the
Washington Post the New York Times and
the Washington star since 1990 he has
been a regular commentator on National
Public Radio and also conceived Road and
narrated to frontline public television
documentaries earlier there was a career
in law another lawyer in private
practice and in government service where
his positions included serving in the US
Department of Justice as assistant
attorney general from 1966 to 1969 along
the way he was also program officer in
charge of social development for the
Ford Foundation and began his life in
public service as a case worker for the
Cuyahoga County Ohio welfare department
he is also the author of a forthcoming
as yet untitled book on the founding
fathers and african-american identity
mr. wolf
you
Thank You Nancy I'm really delighted to
be here I want to go second but my new
best friend cinder Stanton said that she
wanted to go second and she told me I
say well what are you going to say well
I'm going to say like things and then
you can go global she said so I'm gonna
go global because she told me I had to
go global um I want to say first of all
that I think that Jefferson I like him a
lot and I accept him home I don't I
don't admire the fact that he owned
slaves but I understand that most of us
find ways in our time not to do the
entirely moral thing there are homeless
people in this society I got two houses
when I give them all away and give the
money to the home I don't do that some
stage somebody may say of me that man
walked around being a big-time liberal
worrying about people but he didn't make
the sacrifices that were necessary that
is not to say that I excused Jefferson
for having been a slave or it is simply
to say that that is not the only thing
about Thomas Jefferson and I really do
believe that without George Washington
we will have had a country but without
Thomas Jefferson we wouldn't be the
country that we are now having said that
I won't tell you that I read dr.
professor Gordon reads book
with care and interest in things she has
done a magnificent job she does not come
to the conclusion she does not come to
any conclusion other than that some very
noted historians have ill-served history
truth and us as consumers of their work
I find her work persuasive as a lawyer
and as a recent some kind of historian I
find it persuasive because of the
careful way in which she constructs her
arguments
and the role of the arguments but I find
it persuasive for another reason I find
it persuasive from my experience as a
black man in America because what she
says the historians did in protecting
their version of Thomas Jefferson
is what lots and lots of white people
have done through the centuries when
protecting the myths of whiteness or
white identity or white privilege and a
lot of people not all white people
surely but a lot of people and not all
of them are stupid or uneducated or
unprofessional but they've done time and
time and time again
the first person I would cite would be
Thomas Jefferson himself in notes on the
state of Virginia when he describes
blacks as ugly
stupid smelly and lazy
here is a man of surpassing intelligence
who didn't pause in that analysis long
enough to ask himself why the people he
was observing were in the condition that
he described later in the Supreme Court
in the 19th century after the Congress
passed in the country adopted the 13th
14th and 15th amendments to the
Constitution of the United States which
were designed to make the former slaves
full citizens the Supreme Court of the
United States in a series of decisions
these were not stupid men these were not
uneducated men these were not men with
untrained minds but for example there
was just a series of decisions which
essentially eviscerated all three of
those amendments and which reached those
conclusions against the weight of the
evidence that was before the court or
against common sense two examples the
civil rights cases in 1883 striking down
the Civil Rights Act of 1875 1883 less
than twenty years after slavery had been
abolished the court said
of these people whose labor had been
stolen from them over a lifetime whom it
had been illegal to educate who were
being forced back into a kind of semi
slavery in order to support the economy
of the south the Supreme Court of the
United States and all its majesty said
there comes a time in the course of
human events when a people has to cease
being the special favorite of the laws
and take their place among ordinary men
these the court was talking of people on
whose wrists the scars of shackles still
appeared the special favorite of the
laws or Plessy against Ferguson which
constitutionalized segregation a
constitutional form of shunning
design clearly to clear out black people
out of good places that white people
wanted for themselves and the corn in
all its majesty said this doesn't confer
higher status on one or lower status on
the other end to the extent that black
people think that it does it's all in
their minds in fact
I think that the racism in our society
has proceeded in part on a kind of
assumption by white Americans not all
white Americans but some and again some
who are very well trained of a kind of
psychic sovereignty they take unto
themselves the right to tell all the
stories certainly the right to define
who they themselves are and also define
who and what blacks are and even what
goes on in the minds of black people for
example of very a man who became a
distinguished social scientist wrote in
a dissertation at Columbia University in
1910 the Negro has little home
conscience or love of home no local
attachment of the better sort
he has no pride of ancestry and he is
not influenced by the lives of great men
the Negro has few ideals and perhaps no
lasting adherence to an aspiration
toward real worth he has little
conception of the meaning of virtue
truth honor manhood integrity he is
shiftless untidy indolent he does not
know the value of his word or the
meaning words in general he recognizes
no causal relation between stability and
prosperity young educated Negroes are
not a force for good
in the community but for evil they feel
manual labor is beneath their dignity
they are fitted to do no other they
sneer at the idea of work and bus spread
dissatisfaction among the members of
their race the negro woman constitutes a
serious feature of the situation she
fails to assist the man in a better
struggle she is inefficient and
indisposed to be faithful she is a
hindrance to the saving of money and the
industrial development of the family
that's really what happened to Madison
Hemings people decided that they could
just define him as too insignificant a
human being for his word to be taken as
any significant evidence whatsoever he
is dismissed as a poor old colored man
seeking some prestige
and that's a argument that the character
argument sweeps away all else is
repeated in a highly praised new book by
Joseph Ellis Americans faith the
character of Thomas Jefferson Joseph
Ellis had the had the advantage of
having read professor Gordon reads book
before he wrote this and he speaks of it
with some praise but when he himself
comes to discuss the issue of whether
this occurred or not he says after five
years mulling over the huge cachet of
evidence that does exist on the thought
and character of the historical
Jefferson I have concluded that the
likelihood of a liaison with Sally
Hemings is remote two pieces of
circumstantial evidence strike me is
telling first Sally's last two children
Madison and estin were born after
calendars charges created the public
scandal in eighteen two and it is
difficult to believe that Jefferson
would have proposed it persisted in
producing progeny with Sally once the
secret had been exposed and the
Federalist press was poised to report it
second among Jefferson's contemporaries
neither Hamilton nor Adams both of whom
were political enemies who undoubtedly
enjoyed the sight of their chief
adversary being stigmatized by the kind
of innuendo he had spread against them
found it possible to believe that
calendars accusation were true what
Hamilton and both Adams is understood
about Jefferson and what my only
emergence in historical evidence has
caused me to conclude as well is that
for most of his adult life he lacked the
capacity for the direct and physical
expression of his sexual energies
henry adams's put it most explicitly
when he said that Jefferson's
temperament was almost feminist and
scholarly defenders like Dumas Malone
and Merrill Peterson claimed that
Jefferson was not the kind of man to
engage in illicit sex with interactive
mulatto slaves they were right
for reasons that went deeper than
matters of male gallantry and
aristocratic honor
Jefferson consummated his relations with
women at a more rarefied level where the
palpable realities of physical intimacy
were routinely sub sublime to safer and
more sentimental reasons he may be right
but that does not relieve him of the
obligation of dealing with the arguments
that Professor Gordon Reid made he could
have written that and walked away from
the issue
had he not read her book but just can't
write that and say and not deal with the
fact for example that all of Hemings
children were born after Jefferson spent
some time at Monticello
or that his release of the Hemings
children was extraordinary for Jefferson
he can do it for anybody else not to
release valuable slaves of that age but
if you're going to deal with
circumstantial evidence about what
Jefferson might do after calendar put
his stuff out there you surely have to
deal with this and to him I would say
heck you talk about Jefferson's
character from the material you've read
I would come at it from another way I
assess it from having been a male human
being for just a shade under 65 years
and being this father of a 32 year old
male human being I think it's highly
possible so in the end I don't make a
case for it or against it I surely make
a case for the enormous careful work
that
professor Gordon Reid has done it she
has written an admirable book but I
think the case also has to be made that
we Americans have suffered greatly over
our inability to face our history
honestly and honorably and it's getting
mighty late in the day for us to be
living by myths you know it is not going
to hurt Thomas Jefferson one whit if it
turned out that this would true make
them a lot more human to me but that's
but but it is not really whether it was
true or not it is whether the historians
who are telling us these stories about
one of our most important figures can't
muster the emotional will to give us a
fair shot at history thank you very much
yes the secret pickup of the flower
I had difficulty hearing
first I wanna congratulate you
research search is very familiar to me
I'm also
and absolutely wonderful and we're
putting together a book so that you read
the original interview with both Madison
penny and Isaac Jefferson with totally
new eyes having read the whole rest of
the book that was marvelous I'd like to
ask you a little bit about our history
and that is it I don't know how many
people know that Sally Hemings was mrs.
Jefferson's half-sister was the art of
the Jefferson daughters and also going
to always be looked very like her and
was white can you
I'm afraid um I supply banked out there
um the question is about oral history
about dealing with oral history how did
I deal with it or about no it's about
exactly about specifically look I only
look like oh the whales connection well
that's an interesting question here
because that is a story that has been
accepted by historians without the same
demand for the high level of proof that
I was talking about it's it comes from
Madison Hemings from Isaac Jefferson and
I had a newspaper report that I decided
and discovered but it's been another
other Jefferson biographies but this
aspect of the letter has never been
printed a gentleman named Thomas Turner
wrote in a Boston newspaper in 1805 that
there was a connection between this
connection that you're talking about
between Sally Hemings and Martha Wales I
don't know specifically about what she
was supposed to look like that she
looked like Martha Wales I mean that was
I think of some lines of foreign brownie
that in that if they were sisters if
there's a possibility that they may have
resembled one another and that might
explain
she said why Jefferson might have been
attracted to her but I have you know of
any written thing that indicates no I
think that that's that was basically a
surmise the about the resemblance but
the relationship is something that comes
down through oral history and also from
the statement that I mentioned before
and I think historians believe it
because Jefferson acted towards the
family with as if they were favored and
so this was the idea was that this is
the basis of it because of that
relationship
yes sir I wonder whether you catch more
significance to what may have been oral
history in 1870 than to the oral history
provided by the Brahmin family in the
eighteen fifties - Henry problem no I
don't well the idea was to try to
present both of the histories in the
back of the book and I discussed it in
the book and sort of give my ideas about
both you know the strengths and
weaknesses of both of them it's not a
matter of viewing one or privileges one
over another
it's the idea was to sort of bring
Madison Hemings up because as I'd
mentioned in my talk the typical
statement is that there's no evidence
that this ever happened and I wanted to
bring his statement to have it alongside
that of the Randolph family story and to
present it to have people read it and
make their judgments about it now it's
not a matter of off the bat saying
because this is oral history or it's a
history from a black person we should
believe it over the history of the
family the idea was to have them play
off against one another and to present
them both as items of evidence of that
of a random oral history Oprah or
perhaps oral and written history of
David eighteen fifties and they passed
Hemings or history was eighteen
what I mean what what flows from that I
mean that one was first it would seem to
me that the war of 1850 would have been
fresher than the foreign history of 1870
and consequently
credible well gee I don't know not about
who your father was I think you would
probably if you thought someone was your
father I think you'd remember that
forever I mean that's essentially what
Madison Hemings is saying the oral
history of the Randolph's is them is um
was presented by Henry Randall in a
conversation that he had with Jefferson
Randolph about a decade earlier he was
reviewers remembering that we have not
Jefferson Randolph's own words but his
words filtered through someone else I
mean this is not to say that it's
meaningless but as to whether or not I
mean terms of the credibility the nature
of the thing that Madison Hemings is
saying he obviously for summary believed
that Jefferson was his father is
something I as I said I think would
stick with you you know for a long time
I'm not sure that that the timing here
really really matters as much as the
nature and the substance of what the
people are saying and the only thing to
do is to present both of them and to no
problems that exist with both of them
and note the strengths of both of them
as well and just compare them of that
period well I'm putting all of those
things together when I see the Randolph
history I mean Ellen Coolidge
and Henry Randall's letter all three of
them are in the Madison Hemings and
statement Israel Jefferson miss Coolidge
is letter and Randall's letter or in the
book so no not one is not to be
privileged over the other they're all
there and I want people that's one of
the things that I wanted to do and I'm
still in mourning for my footnotes that
were cut because I've been I've been
informed that people are afraid of
footnotes I happen to love them but I
wanted to put as much information as I
could for people to see it believe it
one way or other however you come out
but once and for all this is what is
there and and for people to look at it
did it work
we member mr. Jefferson's we always
refer to mr. Jefferson correctly we in
the dog remember his remains lie even
the relax of his hair are located and
then we may out more now about through
gene studies about DNA what about the
possibility of doing a DNA essay between
mr. Jefferson's remains and those who
think themselves the actual descendants
of Thomas Jones repeat the question this
is a question about DNA and I can't
claim to be an expert on that the people
that I've talked to about that issue say
that it would require a sample of bone
would it be from Jefferson from Sally
Hemings and one of the children to make
anything definitive people one thing I
do know about DNA is the DNA is not like
a fingerprint it would still be solved
on the basis of probabilities and so I
think that even if you were to do
something like that if there was a 1%
probability that it wasn't true we'd
still be in the same position we're in
today so there's not going to be any
definitive proof nobody knows where
Sally Hemings is both is buried so I
mean something and something like that I
mean the idea of digging someone up for
something like this is just ghoulish is
the word you want to use um is um I I
mean I would like to see some issue
involving black people's humanity
resolved without resort to that kind of
thing I mean you know it will be
reasonable if you send the army down and
make us or the court orders us if you
dig Jefferson up and prove it to us uh
it's not worth that I mean and the very
effort to do it I think is still further
is insulting the idea I mean that the
notion that
it would come to that I understand that
the interest in doing it because people
raise it all the time but it that is
seems to me out of bounds now it may be
that I have this thing about the idea of
digging people against it but that's my
reaction to that is typically its but if
it could be done without that kind of
thing maybe sometime in the future it
will be something that's possible and
then that would be fine
but absent something that could be done
without something so drastic I would
rather people make their decision on
their own or just not think about it at
all whatever you want to do I read your
book with great enjoyment but I think
that a lot of this issue gets to them as
what to the global issue of the price
about the fact that many many
african-americans in this country are
related by blood to many many white
people five hundred thousand close to
500 thousand visible a lot in 1860
census says that in the preceding years
there had been a great deal of mixing so
the issue was always one that was very
untalked about and yet under talked
about under the house it under the
covers
but today that issue is still what that
for many people is very difficult and
painful the idea that there would be
white that there would be these white
children of slavery or almost white
people held in slavery by their actual
kin all of those issues are very painful
for an awful lot of historians and the
public and the fact that even today
there are color hue issues between and
betwixt African Americans and the whole
notion of multicultural and diverse all
of those issues are still with us and so
the issue of Jefferson and Sally Hemings
becomes it kind of becomes that the
target what do you call those holes as
we put the catch the lightning lightning
my tips you know becomes the lightning
rod for that issue and that's why I
think we're still discussing that yes
it's a fascinating thing that you've
said because as I was going through this
and looking at this and talking about
the Randolph letter Randall's letter
about Jeff and his conversation with
Jefferson Randolph and Allen Coolidge's
letter whether it's that Jefferson was
the father or the Carr brothers or
whatever this is about one family that
shared a bloodline and one part of that
bloodline was cast out because of their
race they're not talking about I mean
Ellen Coolidge at one point is
discussing these people and she could be
talking about you know a herd of sheep I
mean these are people who she is saying
that she shared a great grandfather with
a common great-grandfather it's
astonishing so whether it's Jefferson or
the cars this is one family sorting
itself out based on race and that as you
said happened a lot in the south and it
isn't something that black people or
white people feel comfortable of talking
about I mean black people why would you
want to say that you're related to
somebody who would be dishonored by your
presence and their family I mean you
don't want to say I'm related to people
like that you know forget you I don't
want to be involved and it's
uncomfortable for white people because
it means you know what does it mean to
be white if I if my cousin is black I
mean so both groups have difficulty with
the issue and you're right I mean this
this is something that I mean it has a
tremendous symbolic meaning for people
aside from
the practical kind of things that I'm
talking about it's a symbolic and
metaphorical issue which is something
separate certain in your discussion of
other historians use of mr. Jefferson's
fair neighbors and colleagues the
critical rezoning the place is just
another character issue for them and how
has it played out in the same way that
is potential fathering of children by
people to be owned by God well the
typical response to Jefferson's owning
slave is not unlike Rogers I might say
is this notion that was he a notion that
well it was he was a man of his time and
even though there were people who and
this is sort of my answer as well even
though there were people who were
speaking out against slavery and
actually doing something about it by
freeing their slaves this was just
something that he didn't feel it was the
right time he had a plan about the way
emancipation should proceed he didn't
believe in individual emancipations the
idea would be that there would be a
general emancipation and then blacks
would leave and barring that freeing
them on his own was not was just not
going to be in the cards I mean this is
not a good answer because I don't think
they gave a very good answer I mean
there's not a complete answer to this
other that that this was just something
that he couldn't he had a plan about it
and it was not the right time even
though his basic his heart was in the
right place but he just couldn't bring
himself to do it
syndra do you mean you well I think you
might do better Jo Alice's book also
brings up puts together what you've
asked because he takes him to task for
his views on slavery and owning slaves
but releases him when it gets to the
Sally Hemings issue and I think you know
character it issues do bear on that
Jefferson was a master of rationalizing
and denial and that affected his views
of blacks and on slavery and you know
the dist
well it's now that I mean I'm thinking
more clearly about this that I was at
first
it's the way they handle it I mean it's
difficult for them because if you accept
it's like they accept all of these
colors you said these contradictions you
know he could say all men are created
equal but then right the things that he
says in the in the notes in the state of
Virginia and you know be against slavery
and own slaves but somehow when you get
to that particular issue but he would've
been utterly consistent on that one and
it's not it's not a satisfactory working
of that because I you know just because
again he's contradictory in some ways
doesn't mean he's contradictory in all
ways but you have to allow for the
possibility the fact that they don't
allow for the possibility that this may
have been a contradiction is part of the
critique of the way they handle the
subject as a matter of looking at a
problem
please join us downstairs is a reception
more discussion with the speakers and an
opportunity to the book thank you very
much
hmm